What it will last three months.
I don't think there ever will be a pepsi needs to be another name in festival but it
but it's interesting to speculate i think the. The two thousand will obviously be and i mean to stop. You know.
Not not too often dealing through the change of a millennium.
But it'll be a momentous time for a strike because it does represent the. This and in the theater rationing and.
As all the point is after a time to a straggler to look to.
You know to what its future is going to be in the twenty first century. That.
It's interesting i think that the celebrations that do happen
and i'm convinced that they'll be fairly interesting celebrations way though the way the way of.
Hosting the olympics in the year two thousand and not i think.
I thought exactly relevant but i think that the celebrations will happen anyway.
But i think it will be very much about.
Seeing that changed role on them and who knows that there's another sort of unicef
and i tease them on them till that time too and how much you've strayed you will get through
and that point of time i'm not sure but i was not sure i would call that another name and i think that.
What that celebrations are going to be that is really a straddle having arrived in southeast asia and and.
Having grown up. And i think right now we'll find that. Very exciting i mean i think the time.
Not too many people probably a lot of people like you with of. The forms of it i don't think too many people really i.q.
With the fact that it's that a strategy was nasty ending on its own two feet. In spite of the world.
And i guess the other the difference with that is is that.
Nimbin was very much about a six in of a strike i think it was if you like that.
What i sometimes call the same sort of antenna on the horns of a rhinoceros it was.
Sort of people who had they had happened after sort of realized that the changes were happening.
Dylan's line something's happening but you don't know what it is do you mr jones.
It wasn't the whole of the straightest celebrating.
I think in a sense in the bicentenary the step was a much more general celebration ally there were people rightly
saying that. You know that there are certain things in australia that we you know.
Have to think very much about what we were celebrating and why.
To me that would celebrate as an act of it but i mean it always.
It always big so question about what and why celebrate.
And if you apply that to the two thousand what it leads you into is some pretty deep thinking about that.
The framework of culture. And i think that.
My hope for the two thousand is if there is a celebration of will be constructive wide celebration of used
and celebration that all of stratton's can take poteen.
And for that to be a valid celebration i think you will have to come to the ends finally with the average english you.
And i think there are any simple answers to the aboriginal question
but if we haven't managed to at least come to us with the treaty
and some better understanding of aboriginal straightly by the two thousand and. Think that you know.
We can't really have a valid revelation of struggle. So i think that'll be one dimension.
And then the other dimension will be. We we do stand in relation to southeast asia.
I mean in my mind the celebration for the two thousand is one with a kind of you know.
Balinese galileans i over there and singaporean.
Line dances over there and lying puppets are mean the names are over there
and you know it's a celebration that acknowledges out. A place in the world.
Not a nots festival of lively you're playing an american culture sort of you know. Transplant.
To the supply part of the world. And one might ask why a festival state already before it reflect that.
More than they do. But i think the times are coming. And i think that you know. The celebrations.
Of a straight in the year two thousand and very likely i think that. I'm guessing here but in the you know.
Saving rate using between i think battle be the dimension. We're sort of starting to realize. And grapple.
Distantly and intellectually. With the fact a bit out of southeast asia. But we're not. Grappling with that.
Yet in terms of. What does this mean culturally. I mean you know we we still expect.
Asians i think to learn our language and i always knew coming to us that's ok. We haven't done nearly enough.
Of you know going in the language and learning their ways and then. Exploring the culture.
And as a side i just mean that ants in the in the food in the music but i mean exploring the realities and.
I think that that's if there are any valid dimensions to.
The celebration in the two thousand maybe that is the name of the new the two there is no doubt
and i get frustrated with very much anymore. It's perhaps because of my expectations that.
My expectations are no side because i think in terms of in terms of the price of this change i mean where that where
the i don't really get. Get frustrated with it i guess because of a ride to the point where.
I'm not just tickled enough. Anymore. I think i was when i was younger. To think that i have the answer.
And i think we're all grappling with all these questions at many levels all of the time.
And i don't have any magical answers for any of these things. And i don't think any one else does either.
So the change will always be sort of you know. You know three steps forward here and two step speckly.
I don't really get frustrated by it anymore i just say that the process is. What's interesting about.
But i enjoy the prices enormously enjoyed the i mean i had one less fortunate people i love what i do.
I mean i'll get izing celebrations if no one but you're paid to pay me to do it it's to do it
but i think it's the most enjoyable thing to do that i could possibly could be doing.
So i enjoy that the process of enormously. And always enjoy the product.
If some celebration sort of plays me more than others. But i don't think i get frustrated by that.
I guess sometimes i do. And i guess the nice thing about. About my current situation is that. It's cyclical.
I mean once dealing with a program of celebrations and events through the. If it doesn't happen when you get the way.
Quite alike all the way when you just put it aside going back to next year. And i think we finally.
I mean my satisfaction is that i think we are finally creating it in a strange culture.
We're finally creating that sort of land max i mean the graham dunstan sort of you know saying at one stage that that
he's made of a celebration was. Whether it was something that you may shoot your life by.
Interns of people say look you know i got married before this. The same to the vice and jane.
Or are they've now had a baby.
After name and so the month celebrations become sort of part of the measuring yardsticks of your life you know.
And then once celebrations become a kind of a calendar that people people accept
and that's what that's what i've always been striving to do to try and bring outdoor.
Celebration and events to the point where people sort of accept that it's part of their lives and there's a few that.
I think we always have i mean.
New year's eve for a new strategy for song was sung as i can remember back to when i was a kid was always special.
You didn't concede a gang. To be before the news you strive to be in a social situation and to be.
There's a sense of sad and.
Funny importance about this day that made you want to be active with it was a patio where the prison sort of you know.
Celebration of the fireworks for the. Hundred thousand people and having abba think that.
We had something a four hundred thousand people.
What happened in advertising up them in just a herd instinct the people want to be together. I've always rather.
Admired in the in the south asian cultures which. Which had that all my spilled into them.
And i'm a man in the band spending a bit of time afternoon when i went back in spain sometimes.
The bowels of bengal i've been in central and travelled for about three months through the villages with them.
And i remember very clearly that he would wake up on a certain day and. Nobody needed to an answer.
Just everybody knew that that day was a celebration day in those
and i thought of going off into the rice fields that this.
On this day of you and sort of you know took their plates of.
Horrible she would went down to the river and had a picnic. And in fact.
If there was ever an experience in my life anywhere else close to christ and him and. I went with.
The bowels to a celebration in central maine goal called the me that when they came i was in him and they'd look to
and they said that we were in when i went over to be in goal they took me to this meal
or the prince that was held on the banks of the game. In this little town then of a.
I think it was something like kind of two thousand years every year this mailer would be inhaled. And it was all.
Determined by the noon faces in the calendar.
Bowels right across spain goal no one needed to sort of you know to put up posters
or to announce that the this meal that was held on this day.
Everybody just knew i mean because that was the noon cycle this was the back going up was always help.
And it had always been held for centuries. And this spot.
By the river and these ancient ancient trees were always the spot that was held so i went with this person
and asked by will and he's doing paddy the weather the way it with was very tribal i mean certain people kind of.
You know we played host and then sort of the whole kind of tribal structure would arrive and i would look after them
and fade them in a detain. So we arrive at about a week before the seeing and. And we've been traveling back.
And whatever fit. You know if it. Hours and hours and finally got to the spot in a stable way here.
Mainly it's nothing.
Yeah well that was was a sort of you know a bit of riverbank sort of you know in the age of this saying that there was
nothing that the eye could see for miles in any direction.
So we've been showing that half over the next ten days you'd see these figures on the horizon i mean many people would
walk to this thing and would leave him sort of you know for weeks before so i could walk to it.
You just say these figures slowly coming out over the horizon it might take three four hours for
when you first spotted them by that quest and i thought that you could actually make out any of the features
and then slowly over the sort of ten days just this insight into how many people came to this ng.
Hundred thousand probably ever they say you know sustains a thousand people to slowly kind of or aldin on and on for.
You know. We're one of the few groups that can my cat i might add and.
Just all around me this is a wonderful festival sort of took place. You know people sort of you know.
Brought things bundles under there and sort of you know things in the ball caps and sort of all this. This little.
City sprang up and wonderful concerts happened and wonderful banquets were held and then sort of you know the.
Signal that a pastime for the meal at the end and justice quickly as it all happened everything packed up
and everyone making so this little figures taking four hours to disappear on the horizon.
And we actually stayed until after the whole thing as i have in a way to right back to being this say in the bank with
nothing visible for miles and. Action.
And it's that sort of thing i've always kind of a say in me and my hope all the time. What a pity.
We don't live in a situation that has that sort of deep and instinct
and understanding of what a pretty celebration isn't so much part of al lives that it just happens in that.
You know i do a ball i'm questioning. Sort of why. But i think slowly that is happening.
So these strains are creating a celebrations calendar for themselves.
And finally
and efforts come out of celebrations i mean not that i think we're particularly spiritual religious country
but a minute has sort of it has picked up sort of you know traditions like christmas and whatever but.
I think it's necessarily for that great the would be just raisins but.
But you know they are becoming very real real celebrations.
We do a christmas pageant down here each year that has a cast of thousands
and sort of you know as many people turn up to it as we can possibly sort of you know feed into the place.
And it's interesting seeing these traditions grab and it's got to the point where.
You know people make their own costumes and so there's a communications network
but i think if we almost if we stopped organizing it would happen. And i feel that that's that's that's sort of.
Why don't they achieve winds of name and actually that. I mean you know. The state and a festival happened.
To quiet the lead up and not. Twenty years later. There's a community of people who are still celebrating it.
It's rather interesting talking to a younger generation now because they have no idea.
I mean it's sort of an in the newman festival came out of nowhere
and went to night with as far as i could see that in fact one other interesting story that i like quite often tell me
in one of my trips up to me. Which was a train trip. On the overnight sort of. And all of them express up to lose more.
I got on. Onto the train and sat down in the scary and they were sort of.
They were sort of i to attain young teenagers so. Sitting for five yards away from me.
And one of them was telling the story. About how i can say with he was slightly older and so he was sort of you know.
Telling him the rights. And the story about how to suddenly on one way gained.
All of these thousands of people all over the country just so that somehow got this mysterious signal on it all up
and converged on him then. And in the thinking. If only it was that simple. I mean they were this mysterious.
Of the just sort of drew people like some sort of magnet.
And felt to me that like sort of saying hey do you realize this that of the hundreds of people who put.
Countless i thought now let it go and put a young and old head on young sheldon's.
But i think it's quite interesting i mean i think that. The younger generation and doesn't.
I mean straight is not very good at preserving its own cultural history. I always feel.
I mean partly because we're dominated by. What dylan thomas.
Called the barrier of a common language if we didn't speak english or american. Be a lot easier.
But because i have many of our cultural lack of facts of american films and american and my they were over the years
and british but more recently american. We lose our own cultural history.
I mean the people in the thirty's i mean not just the stratton's of a certain age in a certain new york if you mention
sort of figures like. Ginsburg. Or you know that. John cage other you know the great musical figures or out.
Because they were. And i talking about but mentioned similar. Innovators from the strategy from the thirty's.
You know it's. Most people now you're talking about we're just. We haven't kept their cultural history.
And i think that's continued. You know pretty much the states getting better. But i think that. I mean i actually.
Used to always think in the afternoon been. I used to always think you know was probably a pile we friction.
Of what happened in america and europe and. You know what. What a pity i wasn't in san francisco and missed all that.
Because i never travel before they'd
and in nineteen seventy five seventy six i finally scraped a few dollars together and did my pilgrimage went off
and sort of you know.
It's been a year travelling through the states
and travelling through have been visiting a lot of these places that had been reading about them
and being inspirational to me. And meeting. Meeting people who'd been inspirational.
And we'd often spend some time at the tennessee for a stephen gaskin and sort of went off to finda
and spend some time and to intone and you know countless other kind of you know. Cultural makers. Movement.
And you know i sat down and talked with countless people. Woodstock etc etc.
Then came to a conclusion i've repeated that you know what had happened in the strait.
You know it was by no means standard to made jolly sight more interesting.
Radio in many ways than the things that i had thought. You know perhaps were much better than they were.
But the skill is something we never got around to making in the movie. People got around to making woodstock the movie.
And i think that's the difference where we haven't saw it and perhaps that's a good thing.
I guess for that reason as our cultural tradition probably is not hasn't been is distorted and exaggerated
but you know perhaps in danger of losing it and.
I think it's probably only fairly recently that the younger generation is starting to look past that
and i think a lot of the a lot of the problems in the country a lot of the fact that we don't appreciate the aboriginal
background on their regional here.
Have to do with the fact that we have looked at our culture through the filter of the first pain
and then american culture. And that's why i think.
That cultural shift is so important that we are seeing a stagnant scientists
and i think they will probably come a time when we start researching all of that and digging it out
and saying i like a lot and we had the nimbin festival happen but. You know what.
What was the strategy of the thirty's like what were the sort of you know that the radical movements in the at the.
And that's i think where you land of a view that as will be that some teacher point that traveling up in the triangle
is more divinely unconscious of the fire will these things happen. Because the other side of it i think is.
It's important to appreciate how they do happen. I mean you know. From my experience. Nothing.
And i'm talking here about the area of celebrations and events. The better organized.
The more they look as either happened just by me.
But i have never seen a substantial change in western countries at least.
That's that's worked very well with where there hasn't been enormous planning and energy
and talent whatever that's going into it. And i think it's probably pretty important for people to.
You know to realise that that's the.
That's what makes i mean that they had the vision and the spirit and whatever all important. But silo is the sort of.
It's a metaphor for life a space so i was to getting down to the teen text of thinking how is this going to happen.
What are the mechanics.
It was actually quite interesting i mean in nineteen eighty story i went up and participated in a ten year reading
and this free festival that.
By virtue of people being me up and saying hey the teen years are up to me saying so
and saying well what we can do about it. So he ended up and. The experience was interesting.
I've tried to go back and repeat a little bit the pattern of saving up their waste of time and sort of.
Announced that we were going to sort of hold festival. Creation workshop. We were going to invite anyone.
They want to come along and talk about what this. What this anniversary fist was going to be.
So we ensconced ourselves and bought a factory up there and sort of you know.
I have a couple of days and lot of people hundreds of people probably came through.
All terribly concerned to talk about whether this was going to be about environmental women or aborigines.
And i thought all good you know when when we get all this out of the way when we're.
You know where we've cleared the air
when we know why we're all doing it then we can actually start the planing to my dismay was upon static feet all day
and decided that they actually drew up a real sort of least that's going to be about these things.
And then as far as i can step a seat. No one was left sitting there thinking oh well at the next.
How do we know we did this year tells i had to we organize the food supply.
All of the things that basically the two decks. Peps i take a rather price a view of it. But that was. I think we.
One of the things that struck me from that period was that with would have produced a fairly intellectual.
Place what generation that's.
In since i have originated i think i'm in love with the site many of us have seen it so you know.
Good at conceptual thinking and theorizing that we can think adelies he she is that
when there's not a lot of real basic sort of hands on practical skilling the end perhaps and that's.
Critique of the education system is based in and teaching people how to think conceptually.
We probably need to be thinking celebrations we need to be thinking about teaching people how you do it.
And i don't see a lot of a lot of that happening. I suppose these days it's hot out.
In the period that led up to newman and when i talked about some of the things of static.
We knew somewhat it was a bit of a simpler society of nice days i mean if you we're only nineteen
and you only had a couple of hundred dollars to nine if you were lucky. You could actually get by the first.
The first month's rent on the building and you could actually sort of you know. Grab a seance system drop a stage and.
Instead of a new they stay sisters feeling that everything has become so super professional that it's old you know an
issue got backers and finance and lawyers and you know. You can't do anything. I think that's a bit sad.
Because i think that part of that spirit of name them was. We can do it. Spirit.
That you know that it's not it's not irony in the hands of the entrepreneurs and. The money the money part of town.
But if you can conceive anything strong enough you can do it and i must admit.
When i think back to have even stepped into some of those things it was nice.
But you carried it off as i said the bottom line is that nobody died. And perhaps.
As we know i think what's happened is that the society is becoming increasingly specialized and.
And increasingly professionalised. And maybe that's a good thing.
But i think with young people i think we're probably reaching another one of those watersheds if we're not careful we
going to go right back to way we were
when i came in in the fifty's that things are rotten by this older generation that has all.
All of the finance loss all of the power
and all of the strains on a younger generation that doesn't have a lot of power over their lives and decision making
and obviously the young people that come crashing through all that and do fantastic things but i think he's had.
And i think it's one of the things that time. We're going to have to come to terms with and.
Sometimes i feel that we were close twenty years ago to coming to terms with some of those things and i think we.
All realize they in the lobby realize to be intellectually that there wasn't going to be work for everyone that we're
going to have. Creasing have machines and computers do it. Then we're going to have to.
Not not have to use the joy it was that we were going to arrive at a society where people work less and had malaysia.
We haven't. Chief that we seem to arrive but the society where.
One group of the population works harder than than is you know particularly. Desirable for people to work and the help.
Bunch of the population is irian ited has no access to that and sits on the obama side.
We haven't achieved the right balance and. I'm not sure way of. We have achieved the right.
The right balance of power there. Because it does come back to power.
And i think we've disenfranchised lots of groups in the not any they regionals way.
And danger of decent range rising young people in society. And all sorts of other goods.
So i think we have to grapple with those things and. I think that. I hope there's a way for us for celebrations and.
There's a role for women i mean nimbin seems to me to have become now. By a set of ideas.
And a mental spiritual community as much as a physical community.
And i know lots of people that don't physically leave it in but actually say name in the name and.
Community is of some importance to the lives. And i hope in the that time.
Some of that exploring and radical thinking and innovating is still happening.
Because i think we're so the things that would spit on that first decision. Twenty years ago. With this line of.
Things. Yeah. I remember that one but.
One sticks in my mind of for one reason as you are what you eat which i take as a very basic statement of despite all
the intellectual reasons. I think in terms of whether i can. Munich and. Some of the insights of name and.
In a few words.
That's always had one of the ones that sticks in my mind as is one that robinson used to use quite a bit. Which is.
You are what you eat.
Which is all my very basic stipend saying despite all the fine think you need to actualise ing etc. Basically it's or.
You can reduce it all to very simple things. And the other one. Lost my train of thought for a moment.
There was another one the. It was interesting wasn't. One of the sort of.
If you like slogan
and i think they sings ass flagons because of the few words they can't be any deeper than that one one that.
That always stayed with me was. Was one of the balinese use which is that. We have an hour.
We seem to do everything as well as we can. And i think that was to me bit of a stipend of. The out.
That fullness saw the atlas ness of and in the interesting musically. Musical phrases.
Always sort of stick with the three as we know and other things faded and made a long time since i was a particular
and as a name mandela i guess. Which you know. Certainly gave me great.
Invigoration and energy at the time and still that's. Thank you.